I've seen all of season three I just
want to say congrats and thank you for
making me laugh oh thank you
um do you find now that uh Rob is in a
better mood when rexim is doing better
someone's having okay that's his that's
his adopted children 100 I've also
enjoyed that show uh welcome to wrexham
but that's a whole nother thing
a bunch of questions about season three
uh but Danny I got to start with you
just because I'm a big fan of community
just want to get it out of the way uh
what was it like reading the script for
the first time for the movie and have
you started filming are you filming soon
I don't actually know
in my mind reading the script is is
wonderful we have there's no scripture
but in my mind I play through the
scenarios and it's hilarious from the
jump the twists and turns and it's a
cathartic satisfying conclusion
um no but we've had a lot of meetings
we've had
um some discussions about the story uh
it all sounds really exciting we're
really pumped
um we're kind of in the early stages of
it right now but um everyone is pumped I
mean it's it's truly the prophecy coming
true is uh we owe it to the fans for
believing it for this long and
um I mean we're excited because it's
just it would be nice to just have this
reunion again and to see where all these
characters are at 10 years out from
Greendale it'll be fun yeah I'm I'm very
thankful that it's fine it's actually
happening jumping into why I get to talk
to the two of you uh I've seen all of
season three but I don't know what you
guys are prepared to say about it so
what do you want to tease fans in terms
of what they can look forward to I think
that in season three you are seeing new
alliances
you're seeing people grappling with
their power Carol trying her best to
make it work she has what she thinks she
wants Steve but these people are crazy
and so how do you manage those two I
would say that's that's my little Milo
little tease that's right
um You have to work with some people
sometimes that you don't want to work
with
but truly they will help you get to that
place of success but what is success I
think this season is a lot of characters
grappling with
achievement they've achieved uh certain
things or
they're reevaluating where they're at in
their life and trying to figure out what
they want to achieve and I think that's
kind of the fun thing about all the
characters this year third season we
know who we are
um and we have a little time to grow and
I think our show is kind of dives into
the characters a little bit it's a
little bit more of like character dives
into each each person
um really thinking about their wants
what do they want this year and truly is
that the real want oh yes is that the
real thing that they should be pursuing
I think that's kind of exciting to see
these people this really dysfunctional
family realizing they actually need each
other and Brad's a janitor and I'm a
janitor yes I have so many things to say
about that but um who wants to explain
what a hoodie is
oh hey a hodi is
and you gotta make it fun you can't be
saying these whole titles the whole time
you gotta get a little you know I
remember last year Brad at one time said
uh you know the POS and then I remember
reading it being like what is POS and
then I was like oh he doesn't even say a
piece of [ __ ] anymore he doesn't he
doesn't have time to say that anymore
Brad is so efficient that he's like
you're wasting time right going through
all these titles saying all these things
break it down make it an acronym get
through it let's get the money let's go
I wasn't sure obviously where the season
was going to go when When Brad
um gets released from jail this is
obviously not a he obviously gets
released from jail so what is it like
sort of playing Brad where you're not
sure if he's good or bad because when
you when I'm watching your face I'm like
I'm trying to figure out is he gonna be
good is he gonna be bad and it could go
both ways yes that's the dance the
answer is sometimes I don't know and
it's fun because it's a fun game for me
there's an actor to play
how much do I want to reveal here how
much do I not want to where's the and
honestly where's the camera and some of
these larger group scenes I'll be
thinking about Brad's place within the
group and the camera and wondering if
anyone within uh Brad's orbit is going
to see his reaction to this moment in a
group setting
um that's a fun dance for me because I
think Brad is this schemer he's kind of
looking at things from a macro level but
you don't know if he's reformed and you
don't know his true intentions and
honestly sometimes I don't either
um but I do know what he's driven by and
I do know that
um there is always a game afoot with
Brad and so that's the fun dance is to
see what the game is right now what are
the opportunities for Brad to manipulate
someone or situation uh and let that
sort of inform my acting choices at
Comic-Con Megan mentioned to me that she
knows the ultimate series ending what's
actually going to happen at the very end
and I'm curious if uh if she's told
either of you
oh my god Steve information did she tell
you what it is or she just said she
knows what's funny is I think she
obviously knows I don't want to know as
a fan I want to get there you know
naturally
I don't know if I want to know that
I like to discover things kind of I
would like to know a little bit more
about Brad's backstory I think that
would be interesting for me to know a
little bit more about I have questions
about who hurt him
because that seems like the more and
more I I get to play this character you
know that's the joy of being able to
come back for a third season is you get
to really dive deeper into things and
you revisit certain scenes and certain
Dynamics but it just brings up different
levels and different questions and so
for me the questions are more about
Brad's past
um uh but to me he's becoming even more
and more human but I don't want to know
the end because I I like to be surprised
what was for both of you what was your
reaction when you saw the set for Grim
Studios because it's real nice and I'm
just curious if what because the
production design really went for it yes
it was it really felt you know stepping
onto that set felt like going into a
portal to another world like I was like
oh this is probably what iron's brain
looks like yeah right like that's his
mind Palace and it has that feel to it
and like when you like go in there and
even just the space you know
um logistically you know you have to
cover your feet like you know yeah we
have booties yeah like keep it crazy
when you walk into Grandpa there are
different rules
um that felt right that felt right but
it's going into like a fancy open house
where are your booties here's the floor
plan
um it was just really cool it was just
amazing to see what our I mean just our
incredible like set deck construction
art deck like what they do and how
they're able to just make this this
world exist
um I don't know it was just it's really
impressive and it was fun to kind of
play even though we're in third season
it felt nice to have like a new sort of
environment to um you know to mine for
comedy yeah on that note I gotta stop
I'm just gonna say I'm already looking
forward to season four thank you so much
for your time and good luck with the
rest of your speed dating thank you so
much have a good day later